offset surprised cardi b with a mansion
during her dance hall themed birthday
bash yeah you heard me
a mansion
oh yes honey cardi turned 29 years old
on monday and she celebrated the big day
with a dance hall themed birthday bash
[Music]
the grammy winner rocked blackfish nut
tights black shorts and a gold bra while
she danced and wrapped her hit track wap
alongside megan the stallion
and the bash was star-studded karuchi
tran ella may cuevo tiana taylor tiffany
haddish and winnie harlow were all there
oh snappity snap snap and during the
party offset took the mic and surprised
his wife with quite the gift a huge
house in the dominican republic
but that wasn't the only gift the migos
rapper got her
on sunday offset shared this clip of
cardi rocking her other b-day present a
massive diamond necklace in the shape of
a playboy bunny the wob wrapper rocked
the bling along with stacks of other
diamond accessories to her birthday
dinner where several of cardi's friends
were in attendance
[Music]
rightfully so the mom of two let loose
dancing singing and drinking wine
[Music]
but she said she was saving her energy
for her actual birthday
and it appears she did her birthday
right here's what cardi said at the end
of the night after the party ended okay
[Applause]
[Music]
you